try not to satisfy challenge scythe hit
him up with the most satisfying gift you
got
[Music]
that was difficult let's freaking do
this
okay nothing satisfies me
i feel like i've seen this but i got
bored and i didn't finish watching it
yeah yeah i have no idea what this could
be
this cannot be the satisfying bit i know
is this it this is enough to quench your
satisfactions
what are you some peasants you need a
nobler
taste please what the hell
this is the top it's the spray okay
that's kind of cool with the
neon light i like that actually
that's it okay we get the result
that's cool cool effect
i am not satisfied give me more
oh okay spend them
oh oh i will admit i felt a little
tingle
but not enough to quench my thirst for
satisfaction all right
oh oh
the ball became where does it go it
melts through
holy mackerel whoa that's a
happy ball wow
wow wow
i'm not satisfied but i am impressed god
damn
if i balls every other mind am i right
gamers
hey yo the [ __ ] is this
get out of here oh this sound am i going
to be satisfied with this
vac sealing marshmallows oh that might
be interesting
oh hello i want all the cracks covered
damn
whoa that it that no
no that is not out of the satisfying you
thought i was going to say that but
i didn't which means i wasn't
uh we did this science experiment
in physics class i remember to show
expandation
in vacuum yeah
not satisfying but very very impressive
i will rate it uh five out of ten
yeah i'll rate them now yeah
well someone's worked in retail
okay what the [ __ ] got my modern vaccine
when i got home i noticed perfect
placement by the pharmacist
[Laughter]
that's great dude i just got mine as
well and i actually don't know
uh dude they should have done it on the
butt
i should have asked him hit her up on
the butt they did there
[ __ ] idiots [ __ ] morons
you had a golden chance i could have
gotten 7 000 likes on reddit
what is this the way
[Music]
let's see see what i mean with all the
cracks covering that's nice
very nice i'll give it 6 out of 10.
the color scheme is so pleasant
i love the pleasint you ever watch a
video and you're like oh this is
really impressive i'll just cut to the
end and see the result wow
ryan [ __ ] i can't be the only one who
does this get out of here
especially when they build stuff on
youtube right and the whole process is
just like all right i know i'm just
gonna see
some really cool time lapse shots
but i really just wa i'm just here for
the result
every building video time lapse shot
things didn't go
as planned i'm a bit frustrated but in
the end it worked out and i feel proud
of it
wow thank you cut to the end please what
is this
are they full dumplings what
whoa it's like a oh that's so tucked in
and cute
oh that's way too much effort for a
dumpling who does that
oh that's so squishy like a boob i love
it okay
nine out of ten i'm looking for that 10
out of 10 baby
that's it zero i could build that
so arrogant
so i've seen these and i'm surprised how
popular they are because they just add a
blue filter and
some light but it's surprisingly
effective
guess reddit loves neon and moody rain
that's pretty cool not gonna lie though
uh but it's still a three i mean i'm not
satisfied
there was a quack in the ice oh god damn
it read it
this is why no one likes you reddit you
understand that
that's kind of cute though
that is oddly satisfying yeah yeah six
six the way her dress flows
it's not flowing wow oh
okay it
it doesn't tingle though i gotta get the
tingle sorry three
mongolian way of cutting watermelon
like stabbing a child what the hell give
me the reveal
that's gonna be like a hat
is this it schofenhauer was right pain
always await the pleasure if this is
the greatest of the greatest satisfying
you know the greatest pain is 10 times
worse what is this garbage
get out of here okay i like that i like
this online
now this is the [ __ ] that's what i'm
talking about
whoa it just swit switched so
seaminglessly
oh my god i bet i could build this in
minecraft in my automatic sorting system
very nice oh i love bass
it goes back no yes
i love it that's the best one yet 9.5
do you agree with my ratings are we on
sync so far okay
oh speed climbing right they're crazy
oh bless
i was hoping they would be synchronized
damn that's impressive
i don't know if that's satisfying it's
just hype dude
oh oh i like that a lot
9.3 yes oh i like that
very good
[Laughter]
oh that's amazing 10.
what have we got whoa
whoa so pretty yeah but i get bored come
on
you got bored too this makes me want to
watch those plant growing ones right
they just grab a seed i can't tell if
this is satisfying or horrendous
it's like weirdly uncanny valley i'm
like it's
not supposed to do that i know it is
supposed to do that are you not supposed
to deliver it
yeah when they they just die instantly
and then
what what that makes no sense
everyone's like oh nature so pretty
beautiful we need to protect
no kill there please this is awful that
was a joke by the way just
orange how does it work
damn you nature you win this one oh
geometric shapes love it
oh oh
yeah you go balls no way
get out of here okay i want this
3d printed marble machine i need a 3d
printer now
no way okay i love this
damn
slingshot versus tree branches get
[ __ ] nature i like this you're doing
god's work
californian soil [ __ ] them up finally
the resistance has begun
[ __ ] you nature
whoa oh i could watch that all day love
it slingshot kid
i almost read sling uh slings hot king
all right we got food that is not food
felix oh okay
good to know thought it was a creme
brulee
or something damn
that's just impressive why would you
paint it oh they're just
okay cleaning it damn damn
that is oh i am i love it
that's a nine i'll never give a ten ever
unless it's a dog
what are you doing ew
the [ __ ] don't cut his shoes dude what
are you doing yo
why would you
[Music]
oh bruh
for his new sneakers why would you do
this god it's horrible and i can't look
away
whoa okay i like that a lot what was he
doing there
did my dog scream if i cut a milli
a nano meter
[Music]
how the how horse okay with this
what the [ __ ] is that what do what is a
hoof made of i don't like nature
i don't i don't like it
nah truck getting smashed hope this
gives you satisfaction
[Music]
people get satisfied by this what's
wrong with you
the person that drove that probably got
injured is this satisfying for you
ah you psycho you like this
this is what you like this gets you up
you belong in a psych ward
we need to report 90 000 people to the
fbi what the hell is this
whoa whoa
whoa what
no way get out of here
ow black magic
oh that's sick okay i like that one six
[Applause]
dude this can't be me but anytime i see
like heavy machinery i'm like but what
if you put finger in there
what if you put hand in there why do we
have that in our brain
right you look down on a on a cliff and
you're like
what if i jump
like why would shut up brain what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you i'm not gonna do
that
i can't that's gotta be everyone i'm not
a psychopath you are
shut up
oh that's cool wow
the luggage is so polite they wait for
their turn i love it
oh look at you your turn to go will he
make it he just went for it [ __ ]
madeline damn it still takes you at
least 20 minutes to get your luggage
though so i don't know
it's zero oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's the best one 10 out of 10.
if you feel satisfied smash like
subscribe
subscribe check out new merch if you're
interested
and that's it see you tomorrow
[Music]
explore fart and mushroom poop pads
catch a melon
gobble butt even ones that i can't see
just download it for free
for free [ __ ] download it
yeah i got something for you
[Applause]
you